But still, we don't know how many values are less than any of the numbers in
between the balance of each bin. For example, we wouldn't be able to tell their
proportion less than 175. Ideally, we would want a smaller bin size as possible.
In fact, infinitely small. But look out what happens with this data when we
decrease the bin size. In other words, we increase the number of bins. Here, we
have 50 intervals. Here, a 100 intervals. And notice that the frequency on the
y-axis is getting smaller. Here's 200 intervals. 500 intervals. 1,000 intervals.
And now, you see that the frequency is 1 for a lot of bins. 5,000 intervals.
30,000 intervals. And now at 150,000 intervals, the frequency for each bin is
either 0 or 1. That's because the size of each bin is so small so there is only
1 value in many of the bins or just 0 values. So eventually, if we keep
decreasing the bin size we loose the shape of our distribution. Try it yourself.
I shared a histogram link that illustrates this concept really well. Use the
data set of physics test scores and change the bin size to the smallest possible
bin and see what happens to the frequency.